the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
one correction from last time sorry to
say I forgot a very important factor
when I was telling you what an average
value is if you if you don't put in that
factor it's only half off on the exam
problem that will be given on this so I
would have gotten half off for missing
out on this factor too
all right so remember you have to divide
by n here certainly when you're
integrating over zero to n the Riemann
sum is the numerator here that if I
divide by n on that side I've got to
divide by n on the other side this was
meant to illustrate this idea that we're
dividing by the total here and we are
going to be talking about average value
in more detail not not today though all
right so this has to do with average
value and we'll discuss it in
considerable detail in a couple of days
I guess all right now today I want to
continue I didn't have time to finish my
discussion of the fundamental theorem of
calculus to in any way it's very
important to write it down on the board
twice because you want to see it at
least twice many more times as well so
let's just remind you that the second
version of the fundamental theorem of
calculus says the following it says that
the derivative of an integral gives you
the function back again so here's the
here's the the theorem and the way I'd
like to use it today I started this
discussion last time but we didn't get
into it and this is something that's on
your problem set along with several
other examples is that we can use this
to solve differential equations
and in particular for example we can
solve the equation y prime is equal to 1
over X with this formula namely using an
integral L of X is the integral from 1
to X of DT over T the function f of T
that is just 1 over T now that formula
can be taken to be the starting place
for the derivation of all the properties
of the logarithm function so what we're
going to do right now is we're going to
take this to be the definition of the
logarithm and if we do that then I claim
that we can read off the properties of
the logarithm just about as easily as we
could before and so I'll illustrate that
now and there are a few other examples
of this where somewhat more unfamiliar
functions come up this one is one with
it in theory we we know something about
the first property of this function is
the one that's already given namely its
derivative is 1 over X and we get a lot
of information just out of the fact that
its derivative is 1 over X the other
thing that we need in order to nail down
the function besides its derivative is 1
value of the function because it's
really not defined specified by this
equation only specified up to a constant
by this equation but we nailed down that
constant when we evaluate it at this one
place L of 1 and there we're getting the
integral from 1 to 1 of DT over T which
is 0 and that's the case with all of
these definite integrals if you evaluate
them at their starting places the value
will be 0 and together these two
properties specify this function L of X
uniquely
now the next step is to try to think
about what its properties are and the
first approach to that and this is the
approach that we always take is to maybe
graph the function to get a feeling for
it and so I'm going to take the second
derivative now notice that when you have
a function which is given as an integral
its first derivative is really easy to
compute and then its second derivative
well you have to differentiate whatever
you get so it may or may not be easy but
anyway it's a lot harder in the case
when I start with the function to get to
the second derivative here it's
relatively easy and these are the the
properties that I'm going to use I won't
really use very much more about it than
that
and qualitatively the conclusions that
we can draw from this are first of all
from this for example we see that that
this thing is concave down everyplace
all right and then to get started with
the graph since I see I have a value
here which is L of 1 is equal to 0 I'm
going to throw in the value of the slope
so L prime of 1 which I know is 1 over 1
that's reading off from this equation
here so that's 1 and now I'm ready to
sketch at least a part of the curve so
here's a sketch of the graph here's the
point 1 0 that is x equals 1 y equals 0
and the tangent line I know has slope 1
and the curve is concave down so it's
going to look something like this
incidentally it's also increasing and
that's an important property it's
strictly increasing that's because L
prime of X's is positive and so we can
get from this the following important
definition which again is working
backwards from this definition we can
get to where we started with a log in
our previous discussion namely if I take
the level here
which is why equals 1 then that crosses
the axis someplace and this point is
what we're going to define is e so the
definition of e is that it's the value
such that L of E is equal to 1 and again
the fact that there's exactly one such
place just comes from the fact that this
L prime is positive so that L is
increasing now there's one just one
other feature of this graph that I'm
going to emphasize to you there there's
one other thing which I'm not going to
check which you would ordinarily do with
graphs once it's increasing there are no
critical points and the only other
interesting thing is the ends and it
turns out that the limit as you go down
to 0 is minus infinity as you go over to
the right here it's plus infinity it
does get arbitrarily high it doesn't
level off but I'm not going to discuss
that here instead I'm going to just
remark on one qualitative feature of the
graph which is this remark that the part
which is to the left of 1 is below 0 so
I just want to remark why is L of X
negative for X less than 1 1 maybe don't
have room for that so I'll just put in
here X less than a 1 and I want to give
you two reasons again we're only working
from very first principles here just
that the property that L prime is 1 over
X and L of 1 is 0 so our first reason is
that well I just said it L of 1 is 0 and
L is increasing if you read that
backwards if it gets up to 0 here it
must have been negative before 0
all right so this is one way of seeing
that L of X is negative there's a second
way of seeing it which is equally
important and it has to do with just
manipulation of integrals here I'm going
to start out with L of X and it's
definition which is the integral from 1
to X DT over T and now I'm going to
reverse the order of integration this is
the same by our definition of our
properties of integrals as the integral
from X to one with a minus sign DT over
T all right now I can tell that this
quantity is negative and the reason that
I can tell is that this chunk of it here
this piece of it is is a positive number
right this part is positive and this
part is positive because X is less than
1 so the lower limit is less than the
upper limit and so this is interpreted
the thing in the green box is
interpreted as an area it's an area and
it's so negative a positive quantity is
is is negative minus a positive quantity
is negative
all right so both of these work
perfectly well as interpretations and
it's just to illustrate what we can do
now there's one more manipulation of
integrals that gives us the fanciest
property of the law and that's the last
one that I'm going to do and you have a
similar thing on your homework so I'm
going to prove it this is that as I say
the fanciest property of the log on your
homework by the way you're going to
check that L of 1 over X is equal to
minus Rho of X but we'll do this one
the idea is just to plug in the formula
and see what it gives on the left-hand
side I have 1/2 a B DT over T that's L
of a a B and then that's certainly equal
to the left-hand side and then on the
I'm going to now split this into two
pieces again this is a property of
integrals that if you have an integral
from one place to another you can break
it up into pieces so I'm going to start
at one but then go to a and then I'm
going to continue from a to a B so this
is the question that we have we don't we
haven't proved this what this one is
actually true if we want this to be true
we know by definition L of a B is this
we know we can see it that L of a is
this so the question that we're that
this boils down to is we want to know
that these two things are equal we want
to know that L of B is that other
integral there so let's check it I'm
going to rewrite the integral it's the
integral from sorry from lower limit a
to upper limit a B of DT over T and now
again to illustrate properties of
integrals the key property here that
we're going to have to use is change of
variables this is a kind of a scaled
integral where everything is multiplied
by a factor of a from what we want to
get to this L of B quantity and so this
suggests that we write down T is equal
to a times u that's going to be our
trick and if I use that new variable U
then the change in T DT is ad u
and as a result I can write this as
equal to an integral from let's see DT
is AD U and T is au so I've now
substituted in for the integrand but on
top of this with definite integrals we
also have to check the limits and the
limits work out as follows when T is
equal to a that's the lower limit let's
just take a look T is equal to a times u
so that means that U is equal to what
it's 1 because a times 1 is a alright so
T equals a this is if and only if so
this lower limit which really in
disguise was where T is equal to a
becomes where u is equal to 1 and
similarly when T is equal to a be U is
equal to B so the upper limit here is B
and now if you notice we're just going
to cancel these two factors here and now
we recognize that this is just the same
as the definition of L of B because L of
X is over here in the box and the fact
that I use the letter T there is
irrelevant it works equally well with
the letter U so this is just L of B
which is what we wanted to to show
all right so that's an example and you
have one on your homework which is a
little similar now the last example that
I'm going to discuss of this type I
already mentioned last time which is the
function f of X which is the integral
from 0 to X of e to the minus T squared
DT this one is even more exotic because
unlike the logarithm it's a new function
it really is not any function that you
can express in terms of the functions
that we know already and the approach
always to these new functions is to
think of what their properties are and
the way we think of functions in order
to understand them is to maybe sketch
them and so I'm going to do exactly the
same thing I did over here so what is it
that I can get out of this well
immediately I can figure out what the
derivative is I read it off from the
fundamental theorem it's this I also can
figure out the value at the starting
place in this case the starting place is
0 and the value is 0 and I should check
the second derivative which is also not
so difficult to compute the second
derivative is minus 2x e to the minus x
squared and so now I can see that this
function is increasing because this
derivative is positive it's always
increasing and it's going to be concave
down when X is positive and concave up
when X is negative because there's a
minus sign here so the sign is negative
right this is less than zero when X is
positive and greater than zero when X is
negative and maybe to get started I'll
remind you F of zero zero it's also true
that F prime of zero that just comes
right out of this F prime of 0 is e to
the minus 0 squared which is 1 that
means the tangent line is his again has
slope 1 we do this a lot with functions
we normalize them so that their slopes
of their tangent lines are 1 at
convenient spots so here's the the
tangent line of slope 1 we know this
thing is concave down to the right and
concave up to the left and so it's going
to look something like this
with an inflection point alright now I
want to say one more make one more
remark about this function or maybe two
more remarks about this function before
we go on really you want to know this
graph as well as possible and so they're
just a couple of more features and one
is enormous ly helpful because it cuts
in half all of the work that you have
and that is the property that turns out
that this function is odd namely F of
minus X is equal to minus f of X that's
what's known as an odd function now the
reason why it's odd is that it's the
antiderivative of something that's even
that this function in here is even and
we nailed it down so that it was 0 at 0
another way of interpreting that and let
me show it to you underneath is the
following when we look at its derivative
its derivative of course is the function
e to the e to the X sorry each of the
minus x squared so that's this shape
here all right
and you can see the slope is zero but
fairly close to zero but positive along
here it's getting this is its steepest
point this is the highest point here and
then it's leveling off again the slope
is going down always positive this is
the graph of f prime equals e to the
minus x squared now the interpretation
of the function that's up above is that
the value here is the area from zero to
X so this this is area f of X and you'll
color it in decorate it a little bit so
this area here is f of X now I want to
show you this odd property by using this
symmetry the the graph here is is even
so in other words what's back here is
exactly the same is what's forward but
now there's a reversal because we're
keeping track of the area starting from
zero going forward that's positive if we
go backwards it's counted negatively so
if we went backwards to minus X we get
exactly the same as that green patch
over there we'd get a red patch over
here but it would be counted negatively
all right and that's the the property
that it's odd you can also check this by
properties of integrals directly that
would be that would be just like this
process here all right so it's a
completely analogous to checking this
formula over there all right so that's
one of the comments I wanted to make
about this and why does this save us a
lot of time if we know this is odd well
we know that the shape of this branch is
exactly the reverse or the reflection if
you like of the shape of this one what
we want to do is flip it under the axis
and then reflect it over that way and
that's the symmetry property of the of
the graph of f of X
now the last property that I want to
mention is what's happening with the
ends and at the end there's that there's
an asymptote there's a limit here so
this is an asymptote and the same thing
down here which will be exactly because
of the odd feature this will be exactly
negative the opposite value over here
and you might ask yourself what level is
this exactly now that that level turns
out to be very important quantity its
interpreted down here is the area under
this whole infinite stretch it's all the
way out to infinity so let's see what do
you think it is
ah you're all clueless well maybe not
all of you you're just afraid to say so
it's obvious it's its square root of pi
over two I was right on the tip of your
tongue wasn't it right so this is
actually very unobvious but it's a very
important quantity and it's an amazing
fact that this thing approaches this
number and it's one something that
people worried about for many years
before actually nailing down and so what
I just claimed here is that the limit as
X approaches infinity of f of X is equal
to the square root of pi over 2 and
similarly if you do it to minus infinity
you'll get minus square root of pi over
2 and for this reason people introduce a
new function because they like the
number 1 that this function is Earth
short for error function and it's 2 over
the square root of pi times the integral
from 0 to X e to the minus T squared DT
in other words it's just our original
our previous function x by 2 over the
square root of pi and that's a function
which gets tabulated quite a lot you'll
see it on the internet everywhere and
it's a very important function there are
other normalizations that are used and
those the discussions of the other
normalizations are in your problems this
is this is one of them and another one
is in your exercises the standard normal
distribution now there are tons of
functions like this which are new
functions that we can get at once we
have a tool of integrals and I'll write
down just one or two more just so that
you'll see the variety here's one which
is called a fernell integral on your
problem set
next week we'll do the other fernell
integral we'll look at this one
these functions cannot be expressed in
elementary terms
the one on your homework for this week
was this one this one comes up in free
analysis and I'm going to just tell you
maybe one more such function there's a
function which is called Li of X
logarithmic integral of X which is this
guy the reciprocal of the logarithm the
natural log and the significance of this
one is that Li of X is approximately
equal to the number of primes less than
X and in fact if you can make this as
precise as possible you will be famous
for millennia because this is known as
the Riemann hypothesis whether that
exactly how closely this approximation
occurs but it's a hard problem and
already a century ago the the prime
number theorem which established this
connection was was extremely important
progress in math yeah question is this
stuff you're supposed to understand
that's a good question I love that
question the answer is this is a so we
launched off into something here let me
let me just explain it to you I'm going
to be talking a fair amount more about
this particular function because it's
associated to the normal distribution
and I'm going to let you get familiar
with it what I'm doing here is purely
cultural well after this panel
what I'm doing is purely cultural just
saying they're all law there's a lot of
other beasts out there in the world all
right and one of them is called C of SS
so we'll have of just a very passing
familiarity with one or two of these
functions but they're little literally
dozens and dozens of them the only thing
that you'll need to do with such
functions is things like understanding
the derivative the SEC
derivative and tracking what the
function does sketch in the same way you
did with with any other tools so that's
we're going to do this type of thing
with these functions and you know I'll
have to lead you through if if I wanted
to ask you a question about one of these
functions I have to I have to tell you
exactly what I'm aiming for yeah another
question yeah I did I called these guys
for now integrals sorry the guy's name
is for now it's just named after a
person but and this one allies
logarithmic integral it's not named
after a person logarithm is not
somebody's name so look look in fact
this will be mentioned also on a problem
set but I don't expect you to remember
these names in particular that you
definitely don't want to try to remember
yes another question
the question is will we prove this limit
and the answer is yes if we have time
it'll it'll be in a you know in about a
week or so we're not going to do it now
it takes this old quite a bit of work to
do it okay now I'm going to change gears
now I'm going to shift gears and we're
going to go back to a more a standard
thing which is has to do with just
setting up integrals and this has to do
with understanding where integrals play
a role and they play a role in
cumulative sums in evaluating things
this is much more closely associated
with the first fundamental theorem that
is we'll take today we were talking
about how integrals are formulas for
functions or solutions to differential
equations we're going to go back and
talk about integrals as being the answer
to a question as opposed to what we've
done now so in other words and if the
first example all most of the examples
for now are going to be taken from
geometry later on we'll get to
probability and the first topic is just
areas between curves
here's the idea if you have a couple of
curves that look like this and maybe
like this and you want to start at a
place a and you want to end at a place
of B then you can chop it up the same
way we did with Riemann sums and take a
chunk that looks like this and I'm going
to write the thickness of that chunk
well let's give these things names let's
say the top curve is f of X and the
bottom curve is G of X and then this
thickness is going to be DX that's the
thickness and what is the height well
the height is the difference between the
top value and the bottom value so here
we have f of X minus G of x times DX
this is if you like base times whoops
rock backwards this is height and this
is the base of the rectangle and these
are approximately correct but of course
only in limit when this is an
infinitesimal or is it exactly right in
order to get the whole area I have to
add these guys up so I'm going to
integrate from A to B that's summing
them that's adding them up and that's
going to be my area so that's the that's
the story here now let me just say two
things about this first of all on a very
abstract level before we get started
with details of more complicated
problems the first one is that every
problem that I'm going to be talking
about from now on for several days
involves the following collection of the
following goals I want to identify
something to integrate that's called an
integrand
and I want to identify what are known as
the limits the whole game is simply to
figure out what a B and this quantity is
here whatever it is and the minute we
have that we can calculate the integral
if we like we have numerical procedures
or maybe we have analytic procedures but
anyway we can get at the integral the
goal here is to set them up and in order
to set them up you must know these three
things the lower limit the upper limit
and what we're integrating if you leave
one of these out it's like the following
thing I asked you what the area of this
region is if I left out this end how
could I possibly know I don't even know
where it starts so how can I figure out
what this areas if I haven't identified
what the left side is I can't leave out
the bottom it's sitting here in this
formula because I need to know where it
is and I need to know the top and I need
to know this side those are the four
sides of the figure if I don't
incorporate them into the information
I'll never get anything out so I need to
know everything and I need to know
exactly those things in order to have a
formula for the for the area now when
this gets carried out in practice as we
will do now in our first example it's
more complicated than it looks so here's
our first example find the area between
x equals y squared and y equals X minus
2
right this is our our first example let
me make sure that I chose the example
that I wanted to yeah now there's a
first step in figuring these things out
and this is that you must draw a picture
if you don't draw a picture you'll never
figure out what this area is because
you'll never figure out what's what
between these curves the first curve y
equals x squared is a parabola but it's
X as a function of Y it's pointing this
way so it's this parabola here that's y
equals x squared whoops
x equals y squared the second curve is a
curve is a line of straight line of
slope 1 starting at x equals 2 y equals
0 it goes through this place here which
is 2 over and it has slope 1 so it does
this and this shape in here is what we
mean by the area between the curves now
that we see what it is we have a better
idea of what our goal is if you haven't
drawn it you have no hope
alright now I'm going to describe two
ways of getting it this area here and
the first one the first one is motivated
by the shape that I just described right
here namely I'm going to use it in a
straightforward way I'm going to chop
things up into these vertical pieces
just as I did right there now here's the
difficulty with that the difficulty is
that the upper curve here has one
formula but the lower curve shifts from
being a part of the parabola to being a
part of the straight line that means
that there are two different formulas
for the lower function and the only way
to accommodate that is to separate this
up into two halves separate it out into
two halves I'm going to have to divide
it right here so we must break it into
two pieces and find the integral of one
half and the other half question
you're one step ahead of me well also we
should have to be sure to distinguish
between the top branch and the bottom
branch of the parabola which we're about
to do now in order to distinguish what's
going on I actually have to use multi
colors here and so we will do that first
there's the top part which is orange all
right that's the top part I'll call it
top and then there's the bottom part
which has two halves they are pink and I
guess this is blue all right so now
let's see what's happening the most
important two points that I have to
figure out in order to get started here
well really I'm going to have to figure
out three points I claim I'm going to
have to figure out where this point is
where this point is and where that point
is if I know where these three points
are then I have a chance of knowing
where to start where to end and so forth
another question
the question is why do we need to split
up the area and I think in order to
answer that question further I'm going
to have to go into the details of the
method and then you'll see where it's
necessary all right so the first step is
that I'm going to figure out what these
three points are this one is kind of
easy it's the point zero zero this point
down here and this point up here are
intersections of the two curves I can
identify them by the following equation
I need to see where where these curves
intersect at what well if I plug in X is
y squared I get y equals y squared minus
two and then I can solve this quadratic
equation y squared minus y minus two is
equal to 0 so y minus 2 times y plus 1
is equal to 0 and the this is telling me
that y equals 2 or y equals negative 1
now so I found my is equal to negative 1
that means this point down here has
second entry of negative 1 its first
entry it's x value I can get from this
formula here or the other formula if I
have to square this negative 1 squared
is 1 so that's the that's the formula
for this point and the other point has
2nd entry 2 and again with this formula
y equals x squared I have to square Y to
get X so this is 4
all right now I claim I have enough data
to get started but maybe I'll identify
one more thing I need the top the bottom
left and the bottom right the top is the
formula for this branch of x equals y
squared which is in the positive Y
region and that is y is equal to square
root of x the bottom curve part of the
parabola so this is the bottom left is y
equals minus square root X that's the
other branch of the square root and this
is exactly what you were asking before
and this is we have to distinguish
between these two and the point is these
formulas really are different they're
not the same
now the last bit is the bottom right
chunk here which is this pink part
bottom right and that one is the formula
for the line and that's y equals x minus
2 now I'm ready to find the area it's
going to be in two chunks this is the
left part plus the right part and the
left part and I want to set it up as an
integral I want there to be a DX and
here I want to set up an integral and I
want it to be DX I need to figure out
what the range of X is so first I'm
going to well let's leave ourselves a
little more room than that Oh
just to be safe okay here's the right
okay so here we have our DX now I need
to figure out the starting place and the
ending place so the starting place is
the leftmost place the leftmost place is
over here and X is equal to 0 there so
we're going to travel from this vertical
line to the Green Line over here and
that's from 0 to 1 and the difference
between the orange curve and the blue
curve is what I call top and bottom left
over there so that is square root of x
minus minus square root of x again this
is what I call top and this was this was
bottom but only the left all right
I claim that's giving me the the left
half of this the left section of this
diagram now I'm going to do the right
section of the diagram I start at 1 the
lower limit is 1 and I go all the way to
the this point here which is the last
bit and that's going to be x equals 4
upper limit here is 4 and now I have to
take the difference between the top and
the bottom again the top is square root
of x all over again but the bottom has
changed the bottom is now the quantity X
minus 2 please don't forget your
parentheses there's going to be minus
signs and cancellations
all right now this is almost the end of
the problem the rest of it is routine we
would just have to evaluate these
integrals and fortunately I'm going to
spare you that okay we're not going to
bother to do it that's the easy part
we're not going to do it but I'm going
to show you that there's a much quicker
way with this integral and with this
area calculation right now the quicker
way is what you see when you see how
long this is and you see that there's
another device that you can use that
looks similar in principle to this but
reverses the roles of x and y and the
other device which I'll draw over here
schematically now maybe I'll draw it on
this blackboard here
so method to you like this was method
one and we should call it the hard way
method two which is better in this case
is to use horizontal slices let me draw
the picture at least schematically
here's our here's our picture that we
had before and now instead of slicing it
vertically I'm going to slice it
horizontally like this now the
dimensions are have different names but
the principle is similar the width we
now call dy because it's the change in Y
and this distance here from the left end
to the right end we have to figure out
what the formulas for those those things
are so on the Left maybe I'll draw them
color code it again so here's a left and
whoops orange is right I guess so here
we go so we have the left which is this
green is x equals y squared and the
right which is orange is y equals x
minus 2 and now in order to use this
it's going to turn out that we want to
write X's we want to reverse rolls
we want to write this as X as a function
of Y so we'll write it we'll use it in
this form and now I want to set up the
integral for you this time the area is
equal to an integral in the dy variable
and it's starting place is down here and
it's any place is up there this is the
lowest value of Y and this is the top
value of y we've already computed those
things the lowest level of Y is negative
1 so this is y equals negative 1 and
this top value is y equals 2 so this
goes from negative 1 to 2 and now the
difference is this distance here the
distance between the rightmost point in
the leftmost point those are the two
dimensions so again it's a rectangle but
it's horizontal as long and it's
vertical is very short and what are they
it's the difference between the right
and the left the right hand is y plus 2
and the right hand is Y squared all
right so this is the the formula
what was the question why is it right -
left that's a very important why is it
right - left and that's actually the
point that I was about to make which is
this that y + 2 which is the right is
bigger than Y squared which is the left
so that means that Y plus 2 minus y
squared is positive if you do it
backwards you'll always get a negative
number and you'll always get the wrong
answer
right so this is the this is the right
hand end - the left hand end gives you a
positive number and it's not obvious
actually where you are there's another
double check by the way when you look at
this quantity you see that the ends
pinch and that's exactly the crossover
points that is when y is equal to minus
1 y plus 2 - y squared is equal to 0 and
1 y is equal to 2 y plus 2 - y squared
is equal to 0 and that's not an accident
that's exactly the geometry of the shape
that we picked out there so this is the
technique now this is a much more
routine a integral I'm not going to
carry it out I'll just do one last step
which is that this is y squared over 2
plus 2y minus y cubed over 3 evaluated
at minus 1 + 2 which if we work it out
is 9 halves so we're done for today
and tomorrow we'll do more volumes more
things including 3 dimensions